hi my name is Wes McKinney and I'm here
to give you a quick overview of some of
the things you can do with the pianist's
library for python I just wrote this
book published in last October Python
for data analysis so if you're
interested in these kinds of tools I
suggest that you pick it up it's very
accessible and nice introduction
to get up and running with with Python
and pandas so one of the things that
people use pandas for is for loading
data into python especially larger data
stored in csv files or many different
file formats so here I have a CSV file
containing about a half million rows
some minute bar data for a bunch of
stocks and I'm just going to load in the
apple the Apple data so time series
operations is one big reason why people
use pandas so in this data there's a
column that contains the time stamps as
strings is about five years of data and
I can remove that date column from the
data frame convert it to pandas
timestamp format and set it as the index
of the data frames so now so now the
data frame represents a collection of
time series I've got a little helper
function here to load some more data
later so there are a number of different
indexing conveniences that pandas gives
you so one is to be able to select all
the data points at a particular time
across many days so here if we wanted
all of the ten a-m data which is you
know 15 1500 GMT I could say you know
Apple bars at time time 15 time is a
Python Python object I'm just looking at
the first 10 rows so we get all of the
10 o'clock data but also look and say
you know the price all of the closing
prices on October 15th 2009 by passing a
string for the for the date and it
selects out that subset of the time
series pandas makes it really easy to to
resample time series so if I wanted to
say take the close price column resample
its monthly and compute the mean median
and standard deviation I can specify
that really concisely and get back a
data frame that contains three columns
for each of the three things that I
aggregated it also has moving window
functions so if I wanted to say compute
a 10 day moving standard deviation
compute business daily samples of that
and plot it I can do that in just a
couple of commands another area that is
is very important in the design of the
libraries and data alignment so suppose
that I have two time series which have a
different set of dates I can still add
these together and it automatically
aligns things behind the scenes if I
create a data frame from two unaligned
time series it aligns them and puts the
it conforms the union of the the indexes
and creates a create some nice regularly
indexed rectangular table you can also
do that with combining together two data
frames too here I sub sample the Apple
bar data and the IBM bar data I take a
90 percent sub sample and then I
concatenate them to give them together
and create a new data frame which
contains all of the bar data for both of
the stocks and they this result has a
hierarchical index and I'll talk a bit
more about that a little bit another
area that is very important is in
missing data handling because missing
data is a fact of life in many cases so
here's that little data frame from
earlier if I call the count method it
returns the number of non missing values
in each column but with arithmetic
methods such as statistical methods like
sum and mean here I computed the sum of
the columns and it excluded the missing
values automatically here I competed the
mean of the rows and it excluded the na
s that are found in the B column you can
also drop DNA so here I said drop in a
how equals all and that only drops rows
if they're all in a but if I just do
regular vanilla drop in a it drops any
row that contains in an A I can also
fill n A's with a miss it with this
fixed value or if I have you know time
series or some other form of ordered
data I can do interpolation type methods
like fill forward here's an example
where I take this daily data resample it
to for hourly frequency I can you know
which computes which gives you missing
data with no extra arguments but I can
convert to for hourly and then use the F
fill method with limit three to fill
forward three periods of data for each
day and
is also excellent for doing arms SQL
type group-by operations gives you a
very flexible way to do group operations
on data so your I've got some
essentially randomly generated data that
represents a set of hypothetical stock
portfolios so I've got a data frame of
some portfolios along with an Associated
Industry Classification for the stocks
and also a currency currency
classification so something that I might
want to do is to group by industry and
compute compute means for each of the
columns and the data frames to do that I
say DF group by industries that mean and
that gives me a new data frame
containing industry means now it can
then be say plotted to create a nice a
nice summary of what went on what's
going on in those groups and the data I
can augment that grouping with two group
variables here industries and currencies
and that gives me back a data frame
where that which is now indexed by
industry and currency and you have group
means for each of those pairs there you
can also apply transformations to the
groups to hear.i group by industries and
currency I have a little z-score
function which subtracts the mean
divided by the standard deviation and
now I use the apply method that gives me
a normalized result which I can then
group by the keys again and aggregate
with me instead of aviation and verify
that within each group the mean is
approximately zero and the standard
deviation is is one so this whole
hierarchical indexing business is a key
feature in panda so you might see this
and say well okay what's going on here
so the index is a port is a data
structure which can be which can be
modified but it's you know it's a fixed
quantity on the data frame so here if I
select the momentum column from the data
frame I get back now a series or one
dimensional pan this object which is
indexed by the same industry currency
hierarchical index I can also select
just the tech chunk of the data from the
rows using the IX indexing field and I
can just select out on that little slice
from the data there are core methods for
working with hierarchically indexed data
stack and unstack so stack rotates data
from the columns into the row so here
by stacking this this data frame I
create a one dimensional object which
now has three levels of the next thing
that can be then unstacked so I can say
unstack the industry field and now I get
back a new data frame which has
industries along the columns and then
currency and factor name in the index
pan this is also very good for doing
merge and joint type operations as you
might do in an SQL database so here are
some movie data from the movie lens
movie lens project and so I've got a
yeah it's you know quite a bit of data
and plus it's taking a lot longer to
load because I'm recording a screencast
so you're I have these three data frames
which are linked together here we have
movie date movie metadata movie ratings
and user metadata and these can all be
joined together in a very
straightforward way I use the pandas
merge function to join the ratings and
users and further merge that merge
result with the movie data to create a
single single data frame containing all
of the relevant data that we want to
aggregate so we could then take that
group by title compute the number of
observations for each title and then
select out movies that received at least
a thousand ratings in the dataset for
further analysis so we call that free
titles and that gives us back a
basically a big data structure of a list
of list of movie titles and then we
could do something like group by title
take the rating column compute group
means of that select just the frequently
voted on titles ordered by value and
select the last 20 value so these are
the highest rated movies in the data set
that received at least a thousand
ratings so we can then take those those
titles filter down the data set take
data data title the movie titles filter
just to the set of highest rated titles
you notice the doctor strangelove has a
very long title so I'm going to truncate
that to 25 characters and now I'm gonna
take that filtered master data set group
by title and gender compute mean ratings
and then on
stack the gender field so now I get a
nice data frame illustrating how men and
women voted on these highly rated highly
rated titles and of course we could
change this from mean to count we can
see actually how many ratings are in
each of these groups pandas may actually
makes this kind of you know pivot table
type operation even easier to do by
using the pivot table method I can just
say oh I want to pivot do chorim a pivot
table on the ratings data group by title
and gender aggregate with me and then I
get a nice sort of nicely indexed
arranged to the table out of the results
so doing things with group buys a little
bit more by hand there's a large set of
summary statistics in other ways that
you can slice and dice and analyze
tabular data so if we use the tied value
counts method on the title column that
just gives us back Panda series showing
the number of movie ratings for each of
the titles sorted in descending order so
you can see that you know the Star Wars
movies received a ton of tell the votes
along with American Beauty and that goes
all the way down to the movies that only
received a 1:1 rating there's also
methods like described which gives you a
summary a bunch of summary statistics
for the data and that can of course be
combined with the group by facility to
get a bunch of statistics across
different subsets of the data set so
this is just a quick overview of some
things that you can do with pandas I
hope you find it interesting and use the
library thank you